[Music]
you are right back there
it's a bumpy this this is nothing
i could whip you around again show you
the old loop-de-loop
every family is weird but trust me
mine is the weirdest my dad
is bigfoot what's the next step clothing
line
sneaker endorsement video game deal yes
the bigfoot you wouldn't know it but
i'm a bigfoot too wow
extract oil puts nature first clean oil
by
extract clean oil you've got to be
kidding me
with your fame and influence you can
help stop extract before it's too late
you just got home you can't leave again
what's the point of fame if i don't use
it to make the world a better place
[Music]
why did extract need armed guards if
they've got nothing to hide
breaking news bigfoot has gone missing
what he needs our help
oh boy here we go again
hey guys buckle up so much for no
environmental impact
mom dad
hang on
let's finish this thing together
we're making pancakes hit me
oh [ __ ] trapper don't thank me for your
lousy cats
[Music]
you